نحن لسنا مستعدين للتحدث مع الأشخاص
الذين نكثوا بوعودهم لأننا
تحدثنا إلى أشخاص لم نكن نعتقد أن
برنامجنا النووي
يتطلب منا برنامج الطاقة النووية لدينا تقديم أي
تنازلات أو تقديم أي
تدابير لبناء الثقة
ولكننا شاركنا في العمل.  إيمانًا بأننا
تفاوضنا ، توصلنا إلى اتفاق ، ما
تقوله الولايات المتحدة هو أننا نقوم
بعمل كل ما يمكننا الحصول عليه في
المفاوضات من خلال الصفقة ، فلا بأس
بكل ما لا يمكننا الحصول عليه ،
وستعود لمحاولة الحصول عليك ، هذه ليست
الطريقة  الدول الجادة تتعامل مع بعضها
البعض ، قد تكون الولايات المتحدة معتادة على
فعل ذلك مع العملاء ، لكنهم لا يستطيعون
فعل ذلك مع العراق ، ما مدى خطورة
الوضع الحالي في الخليج ، في اعتقادك ،
مع حاملة طائرات أمريكية
في طريقها من قاذفات B-52 و  في الوقت نفسه
من جانبك قائلاً: انظروا ، لا
نريد تصعيدًا ، لكن سيكون الأمر
مؤلمًا إذا كان هناك بئر واحد ، فستكون هناك
عواقب مؤلمة على الجميع إذا كان
هناك تصعيد.  ضد أوروبا
، فمن المؤكد أن الولايات المتحدة
تخوض حربًا اقتصادية ضد
إيران ، يجب أن توقف الحرب الاقتصادية يعني
استهداف الشعب الإيراني الذي يجب أن
يوقف الولايات المتحدة ليس لديها
الموقف القانوني لا تملك الموقف الأخلاقي
وليس لها الموقف السياسي
ليس لديها
الموقف الدولي لفرض حرب اقتصادية على إيران
إيران ليست مهتمة بالتصعيد
قلنا بوضوح أننا لن
نكون طرفًا لبدء التصعيد ، لكننا
سندافع عن أنفسنا الآن ، لأن كل
هذه الأصول العسكرية في
ممر مائي صغير في  وفي حد ذاته عرضة
للحوادث خاصة عندما يكون لديك
أشخاص مهتمون بالحوادث ،
لذا فإن الحذر الشديد مطلوب
ونعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة
تلعب لعبة خطيرة للغاية